it was meant to be the most exciting
night
for millie and lucy two teenagers
dressed up to watch ariana grande in
concert
it ended up being the most memorable of
evenings
but for the wrong reasons
oh my god 22 people were killed and
hundreds injured
after salman abadi detonated his suicide
bomb
inside the manchester arena
almost four years on and today millie
and lucy
who were badly hurt that night were in
court to share their version of events
to a public inquiry all of a sudden i
felt like
this warm gush of er hit me
and i remember that it just felt really
warm and like
when you jump in a pool and you feel
water near your ears
and i remember just going in a ball
because i didn't know what to do
and i felt my body get thrown about both
friends made their way back into the
seating area dazed and panicked
both suffering from heavy shrapnel
wounds
i was looking at my legs and i could see
holes in my jeans
and i was like touching them to see like
what had happened
at the time i had acrylic nails on and
they were just covered in blood and
it was just yeah i was saying to me like
am i gonna die
lucy was being comforted by security
staff but the extent of her injuries was
a matter
of life and death i remember
my both my feet were throbbing like
really really badly
and i asked john to take my shoes off
and he looked at my feet and was like we
can't take shoes off
and obviously now i realize that if he
took my shoes off i probably
probably would have bled to death around
her
as she lay on a stretcher outside the
arena
lucy told the inquiry there was chaos
this is undoubtedly the most sensitive
section of the inquiry but will be
hugely
important they want to find out what
happened on the night of the attack
through the eyes of the survivors and by
the end of the inquiry
the chairman will establish if and what
failings were made
to ensure it doesn't happen again these
best friends experienced what no person
let alone teenagers should they had
their happiness of the night
ripped away from them but they survived
to tell their story
to help others intimate rasheed sky news
manchester